a defiant giant bull Cynara took once
again to the streets of Brasilia to
greatest supporters in this regard of
isolation measures we are in Brasilia
now to join a spontaneous demonstration
of the people for democracy for freedom
the people who really want Brazil to
move forward freedom above all else
ignoring growing calls for impeachment
and accusations of interfering in police
investigations to protect his sons he
took off his face mask to hug and kiss
supporters the weakened anti lockdown
rallies have become a custom of both
senators hardcore backers even as the
number of coronavirus cases and deaths
has spiraled out of control Brazil is
now the second most affected country in
the world second only to the US a video
of a recent cabinet meeting released by
the country Supreme Court has shocked
many Brazilians as both sonar and his
ministers called for the jailing of
mayors and governors who impose
lockdowns in the country against the
president's will and seemed uninterested
in the surge of the pandemic now in
another blow to both so narrow his ally
US President Donald Trump announced a
ban for travelers from Brazil it's a
really polarized country and President
Bush on arrow likes to to explain for
every everyone that he has a kind of
special relationship with President
Trump so any kind of measure made by US
government in terms of a travel ban can
be a problem in terms of the narrative
of charitable Cynara but specifically we
have a huge number a lot of emotion in
the political debate here and probably
President Wilson Ari you maintain a kind
of a negative narrative about the
coronavirus crisis here as the number of
infections keeps rising health services
are increasingly under strain across the
country with some doctors asking to take
politics out of
the response to the pandemic we have to
let the people that are supposed to make
the decisions make the right decisions
for us to cope with this disease with
the spreading of the disease I think it
should not be a political issue it
should not be a government issue I mean
just the Ministry of Health issue but
this perfect storm of a health crisis
coupled with an increasingly better
political fight appears to leave little
hope for improvement
as the virus keeps hitting with lethal
force alison ramp et al jazeera